- Devant une carte de l'Ukraine
presque immaculée, Volodymyr
Zelensky se tient debout,
à cIl s'adresse aux Russes.
- Des mots forts, prononcés
quelques heures avantavantavant
le début de ce qui se voulait
une opération militaire russe
les troupes jusqu'à la capitale
Kiev.
"Les leur pleur pleur pleur plt
leur propre destin, poursuit-il,
ils bâtissent leur avenir,
contrairement à ce qu'on
la télévision."
Le ton grave, Zelensky
appelle le peuple voisin à
dénoncpar le président Poutine.
Depuis ce discours, l'anci
vedette de la télévision devenue
président de l'Ukraine, s'este :
celle d'un dirigeant fort
au sang froid.
VALENTYNA DYMYTROVA BAIOV,
sciences info. Uni. Jean Moulinn
de l'image d'un leader de
la nation, et Volodymyr Zelensky
a su incarner cette image
n'ont pas forcément voté
pour lui au dépa
- Volodymyr Zelensky avaitcréé t
fin 2018 sa candidature
Il a mené campagne contre
la corruption et pour la paix
dans l
73 % des votes.
Depuis l'invasion russe,
il a troqué son costume-cravate
la couleur militaire.
Et dan de Kiev,
il multiplie les appels
à la mobilisation depui
- Pour tenir bonpespespespespess
ukrainiennes et les citoyens
ukrainiens qui sont concernés
par le conflit, ils ont vraiment
besoin d'avoir le discours quisr
d'unre régulière.
- Saisissant toutes les tribunes
actif sur les réseaux sociaux,
le président ukrainien
se transforme en chef de galorse
dans uonventionnelle.
- C'est l'opposition, un peu,
du monde de... du KGB,
avec le passé lourd soviétique,
et puis quelqu'u
vient du monde des médiasla com.
Et effectivement, Zelensky
très moderne des technologies.
C'est un peu comme le contraste
entre
la tradition.(tumulte)
- En se révélant de la sorte,
a suscité une adhésion
qui dépasse les frontières.
eu lieu en Russie.
bgén RICHARD GIGUÈRE, retraité
des FAC et expert, U. Lavaln, de
certaine façon, cter,cter,cter,,
là, la population russe de
ce qui est jamais une bonnechoÇe
une offensive personnelle
ça fait une grosse différence.-s
d'affrontements, Volodimir
aux côtés des citoyens qui
continuent de se battre jusqu'au
bout. Et sur une base plus
des communications
qu'il ontre Vlad